if you're feeling under the weather stop
what you're doing right now because I'm
going to show you a super effective and
delicious and easy chicken soup there's
a reason your mom always made chicken
soup when you're sick there's actually
some evidence that it may help with
congestion a sore throat and of course
hydration but when I'm sick I don't have
the energy to be making a really hearty
broth from scratch and cooking the
chicken from scratch so I got a few
shortcuts to make this happen step one
order rotisserie chicken and take the
chicken off the bones step two get a box
of bone broth for some extra protein and
flavor step three throw the chicken
bones into the soup huh step four add
some root veggies
add in our chicken chicken soup is
packed with protein selenium zinc and
vitamin C which is really important for
helping to support our immune system
it's also water packed and we know
hydration is so important when we're
battling a cold or flu
hope you guys feel better